alright hello this is a another
instructional video
from pepper panic tips dot com this is
for new players of the game
it's about how peppers work and how to play pepper panic saga
if you're familiar with other King games
candy crush saga
or farm heroes saga in particular
those are match three games and
you know that it works by matching three
pieces of the same color together
in order to achieve goals that
each level has set up for you
pepper panic saga is a match
three-game also
but the peppers work a little bit
different than say the candies in candy
crush saga
so I am gonna load up this level and show you how to play pepper panic saga
it has a big board and a lot of peppers on it so I am going to show
you some of the basics of how peppers work
level 95 is a match patterns level
I'm not going to worry about the
patterns on this or trying to beat
the level I'm just going to show you some basic moves
alright so you can see when we start out
we have a of peppers.  all the papers have 1 dot on them
and they're all small. these are stage 1
peppers
and the objective
in pepper panic saga is to grow
your peppers
and the more you grow them
they will eventually get to their full size and explode
and that's what makes this game fun
is there's a lot of action
compared to some of those other games I
mentioned
so the way we grow a pepper is you match
3 of the same color together
so I am going to move this red one
and now you  see that the new pepper that is left behind
has two dots. now I will do the same with the blue
alright so you see that whenever
we match them together all three
of them don not disappear
like they do in candy crush saga. I guess if you play Farm Heroes Saga and you know
about eggs.  Eggs all combine together in
the spot
of the one that you moved.  so you see that that
when I combine those 3 I have one pepper left behind that is now a bigger size.
so when I match this stage 2 pepper with these others you
can see it grows again
right now it has three dots. one of the things you can do in this game
is you can
combine more than three at a time and
different things will happen
I'm gonna make this match here this is a 4
pepper match
in a straight line and you'll see
that
you'll see that something a little bit
different happens
when I combined those four peppers what
happened was I created what is
called a shockwave. the shockwave
that comes
particularly from a 4pepper match in
a straight line
will clear all the small level all the
small papers are that roe
and grow your one pepper and I see at
the bottom I have this big peper that
is about ready to explode
it also cleared out all the small
peppers in my row
another where you can combine peppers that
can be helpful is
matching them in patterns like this
move. this is going to be a "T" pattern
it's going to be five peppers
that are a combined together of the same
color and the
pattern is going to be a "T". so what
else is going to happen is
this pepper that is
stage 5, you can see by by counting the dot is a 5. its going to explode
when it explodes watch what happens to
the other blue peppers on the board
that was kinda fast so I'll explain
each time you explode a pepper of one color... you grow to its full size and explodes
it will grow all the other peppers of
that color on the board.
you see all the stage one
you know stage one peppers that were
there are now stage two
I'm going to continue to
combine these blue peppers if I can
you can use
I want to grow these right here and they're
already partially grown so
when i connect these four its
gonna can't create another
shockwave like it did
the first time but this time watch
it'll grow these two peppers because
they're not small
and that started
the effect where that
pepper combined with some other ones
that exploded
so this is another one this is a
couple stage two peppers combined with
a stage four pepper that's going to make
that grow big enough to explode
and grew all the other red peppers on the
board
see those were three stage two peppers
combined
it only made it a stage five so it's
ready to explode but it didn't explode
just by that match
here's another four pepper combo you can see the shockwave
this one is going be four and this one is going to serve two purposes, it's going to explode
this pepper that's right to exploit it
also gives you the shockwave at this
one that's gonna make it explodes what's
what happened here
both those papers are very early
Explorer all the other ones that color
that starts a chain reaction which
causes papers all over the board to
start to
explode and it's gonna start what's
called a paper appearing
never panics are cool in the fact that
the
you know they get your last point in the
clear out the board as you can see
after that happen all the other papers
disappeared
in new ones well in that were
stage more that can come in handy also
like if you're trying to make something
and can't get to it
in clear out the board here's the
interesting that this was going to be
too
teens together
for match like they're obviously going
to cause a lot of action that happen on
the border make things
you know good things happen on
these I see that these are ready to
explode
this with great explorer for maker for
paper match here as killers make that
will explore
among other things about making paper
pair X is only have a
a paper like this it's always gonna
explode if the gross one size
a if I can remind these three together
that one peppers going to grow
explode but if I can buy any 3 together
what would happen this one will explode
then that'll cause the kid tree reaction
that causes that led to its cool
so taking your time before you make your
moves is helpful to the
to get the most this for ZTE reactions
are starting prepared
alright as well as making them in the
table tease you can also make a minute
shaper
tells us is to peppers the same color
here to papers in the same color here
in the fifth one that'll fit in between
so whenever I combine those the same
thing happens it happens with the
tedious and up to
shock waves and creates a lot of good
stuff that happened on the board
one worker merced you can do it I'm
tryin to
set one up here somewhere let's see
both working on a paper appearing after
hopefully we'll have some papers filed
place
it said earlier you know this is a bore
the picked on purpose because it has a
lot of
that has allowed wide open space in a
lot of paper arm
the mother levels are once again be a
lot more difficult to
you make the match is that you more amor
move something to pause the video for
second in the murder
loaded up one more time alright so I R
Marie lower the level and missing papers
around the email sorry the last a permit
you have on this is a mess the that is
five papers together
in a straight line and X a little bit
differently than the other
by paper matches that are shaped on when
you match the papers this way where all
do is it'll
it'll grow all the papers on the board
in this case
the same car in this case yellow peppers
in it also
on levels that future the the villain
mister cause intellectually disabled
into so these are good
he's a good matches it does not make the
it does not make a shock wave so you
know you have to use your best judgement
what the better
arm match would be in different
situations but this is just a basic
straight-line
by peppermint you see it all up the
yellow peppers on the board grew I
thought I hope this was helpful to
understand how
peppers work in the game and how you can
use them
a little bit differently than you do you
know K knees or whatever
I mean in a way they're all they all
turn in the Boosters it to grow them
because they explode and that causes a
lot of different things that happened
a I think it's a fun game to play it in
a in a make my website about the game
so I hope your visit in the you know
check out all my videos and other guides
on how to
be particular levels in tips that mean
in the
I'll be making some more videos so I'll
see you soon